obendrauf land präsentiert vorkommt die
krise beim spezialist für den lachs in
nord
konkret punkt ch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
fünf tage 200 kilometer bis minus 20
grad
mit dem husky gespann quer durch die
wildnis lapplands vier frauen und ein
mann erfüllen sich ihren traum
[Musik]
begonnen hat alles vor zwei tagen auf
der huskyfarm des finnischen
hundeführers juli piazza jede und jeder
ist selbst für sein gespannt
verantwortlich vieles ist neu die gruppe
ist mit all den aufgaben noch
überfordert was mache ich jetzt ist
gegen die so was mache ich was mache ich
jetzt metern gepackt so hilflos gefühlt
das team ist am nächsten morgen zu
langsam unterwegs und die verspätung hat
konsequenzen
armin hat seine hunde nicht im griff wir
haben gekämpft und aus dubai und die
faktische die hände gewisses machen
tag 2 anfang dezember
die gruppe ist nach der aufregung des
morgens endlich unterwegs
hundeführer yuko hofft dass sich die
huskies beruhigen wenn sie endlich
laufen können und tatsächlich friedlich
zieht auch das 5 gespanntes
brunnenmeister serbien durch die
abgeschiedenheit finnlands
[Musik]
ihre schlitten haben die fünf schweizer
schon besser im griff jeder führt
proviant und gepäck selber mit bis zu 60
km
[Musik]
der erste stopp nach wenigen kilometern
und kuba hat sich beim kampf am morgen
verletzt
sicherheitshalber nimmt in you go aus
dem gespann es sogar schon bisher bis
mittelgroßer hund und lockte wieder
verletzt sich am 9
nicht viel sehen
die wunde ist nicht groß nur kratzer nur
ein kratzer auf der hand dass an unserem
unabhängigkeitstag am 6 dezember 1917
löste sich finnland aus der russischen
vorherrschaft
seither ist dieser tag der finnische
nationalfeiertag judo verabreicht dem
verletzten gruppe eine tablette und dem
tier eine verschnaufpause
[Musik]
die anderen hunde wollen weiter ich gebe
ihm entzündungshemmende mittel
es ist wirklich nur ein kleiner schnitt
es sieht nicht schlimm aus ich nehme
ihnen meine notfall kiste auf den
schlitten und schauen abend was wir
machen wenn es ihm am morgen nicht
besser geht muss ihn jemand hat das
ballett mit ihm reichen noch 400
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit 39 kilo ist ballack der größte hund
aus us- rudel
[Musik]
eishockey 2
dem alltag entfliehen
eine auszeit nehmen und seine träume
leben
das wirkt wunder
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für die software test managerin silvia
ist dieses abenteuer eine große
herausforderung vor vier jahren ist sie
an parkinson erkrankt perfekt wie geht's
dir sehen wir gut das war wohl das
schwierigste streckenabschnitte ganzen
woche ja ich weiß noch nicht so genau
wie ich mein gewicht einsetzen soll um
richtig zu steuern
jetzt haben wir das zu essen verdient
wie immer zuerst ist für die hunde
chorus wichtigste regel die hunde kommen
immer zuerst
es gibt zuerst für die hunde zu essen es
für euch was gibt steht noch ein
bisschen weiter wir auf die seite
michelle die physiotherapeutin versorgt
sie bevor sie an sich selbst denkt der
starke ballack und armin freunden sich
langsam an und werden zum team
und wie geht es kuka im fahrenden
krankenzimmer wäre einfach zu vorwitzig
kuba ist ein park er ist ein
eineinhalbjähriger frächter
normalerweise haben andere hunde respekt
vor ballack aber die elfer dumm genug
ballack als zuvor
und natürlich hat er verloren ist dass
sein charakter
grubers noch jung und sucht noch seinen
platz in der hunde hier reichen wenn es
einfach aus er hat das vorher noch nie
gemacht aber ich habe schon bemerkt dass
er seinen platz innerhalb des rudels
sumatra ballack herausgefordert es war
nichts erklären
der erste augenblick der ruhe für die
abenteurer
vergessen wir so der ganztages ihre wie
passieren ich muss sagen
23 kilometer bin ich emotional wurde
wäre einfach so so alles auf mich nicht
ab sofort einfach plötzlich mit dem
eigenen schlitten durch ein
wunderschöner war das funktioniert alles
märz ohne seine firma götzfried mir ist
mich glücklich man ist völlig losgelöst
vor allem also natürlich umgebungen
einiges dazu mit dass man einfach nicht
nicht unter den alltag dank auch silvia
genießt die zeit mit den hunden in
vollen zügen
und vergiss die sorgen ihres alltags
dass sich die gruppe ganz einfach aber
ist es völlig egal wie pinsel davon
extrem ich auch ich vergesse meine
parkinson erkrankung und das ist so
wichtig danken schon gut und ich habe
vergessen dass du diese erkrankung
überhaupt
wir sind diesen steilen hügel herunter
gefahren und ich habe gedacht ist das
wirklich sind ich bin eine kämpferin
dieser hügel war anspruchsvoller als
alles was noch kommen wird
es kommt zwar noch größere anstiege aber
die sind viel einfacher
aufgeben kommt für mich nicht in frage
das ist die richtige einstellung
[Musik]
hugo hat wohl aus taktischen gründen
etwas untertrieben mit den
bevorstehenden anstrengungen vor dem
team liegt ein steiler anstieg über 200
meter
es ist gegen 15 uhr und bereits
stockdunkel
jetzt kommt nochmals ein großer anstieg
dann eine abfahrt wir fahren hoch so
schnell es geht wir stoppten oben nicht
und fahren wirklich langsam hinunter
alle zusammen
[Musik]
frauen haltet die augen offen
ja
die runde sind stark doch bei so einem
anstieg müssen die teilnehmer mithelfen
sie dürfen dabei ihren schlitten auf
keinen fall verlieren
auch armin bleibt trotz besonders
starkem gespann die anstrengung nicht
erspart
die ehemalige profi bobfahrerin michele
ist voll in ihrem element
[Musik]
das ist unglaublich browns in das tempo
und verlagen von links und sexy
wellendingen wort ist die scheibe
[Musik]
rivalitäten
auch so
[Musik]
in der finnischen dunkelheit die zu
dieser jahreszeit anfang dezember rund
20 stunden dauert brauchen die
abenteurer vor allem eine gute
koordination
[Musik]
scheiße
um 17 uhr erreichen alle das nachtlager
heute ohne weitere zwischenfälle
wenn die gal wird nicht ruhig dafür
brauche ich bin hellauf begeistert
langsam sitzen die handgriffe und die
hunde werden sofort versorgt gibt die
doppelte menge wurst wirklich ja es war
ein langer tag das wird eine kalte nacht
werden sie brauchen viel energie und
dann füttern wir sie nach ein bis zwei
stunden
barbara ist für dass hundefleisch
zuständig ich zeige euch wo es wasser
gibt wasser schöpfung geht schneller als
schnee schmelzen
es kocht schon wir holen jetzt mehr
wasser wirklich aber der topf ist heiß
juli zeigt silvia wo er eine quelle
entdeckt hat
es gibt ja überall wasser wir müssen nur
klar ist finden
es schmeckt gut sooo lange nicht so viel
dreck hören konnte
wir brauchen mehr ja ich habe den großen
behälter auf meinem schlitten einige
davon
es gibt auch eine kleine quelle hier hat
es immer was wir können sogar unser
trinkwasser von dort dann warten wir ja
der geschmack war nicht ehrlich ich habe
ihn gerade gesagt so viel arbeit hatte
ich das ganze letzte jahr über nicht
nach dem morgen lief alles gut
keine unfälle ich glaube jetzt beginnt
es sich einzuspielen
es ist der morgen passiert die hunde
hatten einfach zu viel energie
das hat selbst mich erstaunt
normalerweise muss ich die leute nicht
warnen dass auf die hunde kommt mit
einander kennt ich hatte noch nie so
viel durcheinander
ich weiß es gibt im moment hündinnen die
häufig werden
das war vielleicht gehört normalerweise
bellen die hunde einfach und wollen aber
in der paarungszeit geht bei den blüten
der testosteronspiegel hoch wir müssen
einfach versuchen die hunde am start
juli schaut nach dem verletzten kuba ich
bin fast sicher ist am anfang viel
schlimmer aus als es war ein kleiner
schnitt die verletzung geht nicht lief
nicht bis auf die muskeln oder das
fleisch so lange wir die wunde sauber
halten sollte er morgen laufen können
ich bin keine schmerzmittel gegeben weil
ich wissen wollte ob er schmerzen hat
mit den medikamenten würde auf jeden
fall auf willst was an dieser kerl hier
ist elf jahre alt und schon locker
30.000 kilometer mit mir gelaufen
jetzt gibt es eine kleine massage für
den alten herren in den steifen retten
das ist der richtige ort
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nach tagen wie diesen freuen sie sich
auf die heiße fleisch suppe erst nachdem
sich die hunde satt gefressen haben
dürfen die teilnehmer an sich denken sie
bekommen selber geschossen sl fleisch
aus yukos jagd ist viel besser geworden
wäre und wer mit der höhe dass ich ihn
ja mit der hand besser kennen und
unterschiedlichster estate kann mit
seiner hündin einen tag lang als kennen
erklärt quasi hört sich immer in einer
beziehung also bin ich möchte etwas über
meinst du die hunde kennen ihn schon
ich glaube die hunde gewöhnen sich an
euch
es ist schon der zweite tag sie sind
immer um dieselbe person die ihnen das
fressen gibt ja dahin läuft vieles über
das essen sie funktionieren relativ
einfach wir sie füttert ist für sie
quasi gott
hohoho heute am sechsten dezember ist
nicht nur finisher nationalfeiertag ist
viel besser kennt landhaus nichts
armin der alleinige einzige wand
ich bin total auflagen kommen aber es
ist nur zwei ziele wo der hübsche mutter
mit kind hätte ich hoffen und einen
wirtin wind michelle auf den kufen profi
war
tiefgründig legt sie uns einfachste
denkt lösungen
martina unser ziel über das küken mit
unserem selbstvertrauen ende der reise
in die liebe hatte immer denkt so
positiv mit dem dunklen orten ganz
kreativ
hu jo unser führer auf der tour
ob runter oder rauf er hat einen langen
stau
[Musik]
morgen läuft es gleich wie heute wir
sollten um sechs aufstehen denn wir sind
etwas langsam und wir sollten noch
effizienter werden nicht darum trügen
eine person kümmert sich um den kopf für
das hundefutter und bleibt auch dort
eine macht das thema asse und geht nicht
weg ich nenne jetzt keinen namen aber
schaut wirklich dass ihr kontinuierlich
neuen schnee in den unten hinein schauen
dass die flamme immer groß genug und das
andere das hat selbst mich die hunde
haben eine wahnsinnige das ist zwar toll
wenn es uns rennen aber vor dem start
kann es gefährlich werden
sie sind so aufgeladen am morgen es geht
noch so lange sie an der nacht leine
sind aber sobald wir ihnen das
laufgeschäft anzieht geht der
energiepegel hoch war wahrscheinlich
noch nie in einen streit verwickelt
ich habe nicht gesehen wie es angefangen
hat aber ich bin sicher cooper hat ihn
provoziert und am schluss musste ich ihn
den ganzen tag auf dem schlitten
hinterher 2 passt von jetzt an auf am
morgen ist in ordnung wenn sie mit dem
schwanz wedeln und glücklich sind ist es
okay aber sobald er hört dass der ton
ändert wenn sie aggressiv werden und
ihre freunde muster was machst du wenn
sie anfangen einander an zu schreien und
da bildet es sofort das ist nicht
erlaubt
hat jemand verletzt und wir sind
aufgeschlossen die hälfte des teams bei
mir in der notfall box landet also ich
jedenfalls sonst habt ihr es gut gemacht
auch das war
die temperatur ist deutlich gefallen es
sind jetzt eisige minus 20 grad
[Musik]
die fünf abenteurer haben schon wieder
verschlafen
sie sind fast eine stunde zu spät dran
es ist schon fast 7 uhr geht's los
[Musik]
die schweizer uhr hat nicht funktioniert
ist ihrem ruf nicht gerecht geworden
der alarm ist nicht losgegangen der
einzige der wach war von ihnen kam kein
lebenszeichen
wir machen heute keine lange mittagsrast
denn wir müssen noch im tageslicht in
groß möge
wir führen die thermosflaschen und essen
unterwegs
heute steht die königsetappe an mit dem
alice tun dem höchsten punkt der tour
einem hügel mit einem harten aufstieg
auf 200 meter er sieht gut aus
es ist jetzt etwa halb neun das zählt
ist leergeräumt für hunde sind für
gefüttert worden
ich bin wirklich erfreut über diese
steigen
jetzt muss ich mich mit meinem zelt
bereiten dass ich nicht die lahme ente
bin auch das anspannen läuft heute schon
viel besser grußworte haben gewirkt
[Applaus]
das ist doch dabei missbrauchen die
respekt muss man nicht haben so gut
geordnet und dem kopf hat
und wie geht es der patientin der jungen
punk gruppe
er kann heute laufen
ich habe gestern vielleicht etwas
übertrieben
der schnitt weit war so groß ist die
wunde geschlossen
kein blut nur eine kleine verletzung
aber du nimmst du ja ich will schauen ob
der nächste stopp wirklich bestätigt er
liebt es zu rennen da wird man ihm
nichts anmerken
er wird mir vorspiel dass alles gut ist
alles ist heute viel ruhiger als gestern
eine rolle die auch barbara spürt die
mutter und psychologin
das war zwar nicht ist ja die letzten
jahre sind sind schon oft sehr sie
hatten ihren länger weg
nun kann ich das natürlich
ich bin sehr optimistisch
ein gesuchter idealistisch und ich
glaube dass die truhe und negative
emotionen endlich haben auch blogs and
verdauen muss ich eine pizza und seine
gäste zu knacken unterwegs gesehen
und dann geht es los auf die 40
kilometer strecke zum alice tom dooley
[Musik]
manchmal ist es an der zeit aus dem
alltag auszubrechen und seinem leben ein
neues kapitel hinzuzufügen
[Musik]
seit er durch
langsam runter fahren
wien
euro' zieht durch er will den
angekündigten harten anstieg mit den
schweizern unbedingt noch bei tageslicht
erreichen
noch bleiben zwei stunden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
deshalb gibt es heute nur eine ganz
kurze pause damit sich die hunde für die
bevorstehenden anstrengungen stärken
können
[Musik]
80 portionen ja was uns egal dass mir
sehe und nach abruf man gesteht auch
dass wenn du es foto gehe ich das nur
beendete den handel forschung gibt es
die natur schützen
[Musik]
martina die hr managerin spürt
inzwischen die anstrengung spiel sehen
also weder westside mobilisiert ist ein
relativ gut gegangen ich habe immer
wieder dass ab und das dankt sie vor der
trailer
ob er jetzt kann man über ein großer see
so viel ich sehe keinen sinn die flucht
das hat mir da während im seefahrer als
letzter gast
das funktionierte nach gott
die hunde kennen keine müdigkeit und
wollen weiter natürlich nicht
da hilft nur das handy weg gemacht
wir machen
übrigens zauber
die einjährige mayday ist die einzige
die jetzt über den see eine kurze pause
bekommt sie ist zum ersten mal auf einer
solch langen tour dabei euroville sie
für den aufstieg auf den alles kultury
schonen
[Musik]
damit die huskies nicht zu schnell
werden müssen die teilnehmer dauernd auf
der bremse stehen
[Musik]
nachdem sie setzt yahoo die einjährige
mayday wieder ins team ein und zieht
gleich weiter es ist gegen 14 uhr und
das licht schwindet bereits wieder das
gelände wird immer unebener seit vier
stunden stehen sie jetzt schon auf den
schlitten ein körperlicher und
koordinative kraftakt für alle besonders
für silvia
[Musik]
alles in ordnung
nichts passiert silvia vergiss nicht zu
bremsen
bist du eingeschlafen ich habe schon
gebremst ich bin auf der metallplatte
gestanden
ja aber du bist vielleicht schon etwas
schläfrig unterwegs die bremse benutzen
die bremse das war ein weckruf
ja genau
erst gegen 15 uhr erreichen sie den
anstieg zur listung durch
fast bei tageslicht fast wir sind schon
weit wie weit nach
jetzt geht es nur noch hoch und dann
zündete ein flaches stück mehr von jetzt
darin eine stunde genau
[Musik]
den 200 meter steilen anstieg müssen sie
nun im dunkeln bewältigen was die sache
nicht leichter macht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gegen 16 uhr dann die erlösung
das ist mir das leid nicht die hoffnung
dass in einer so stark sind ja noch fünf
patiniert dank krampf ist hier gern
krampf
das ist wirklich die gesamte who und das
tut einem richtig dass jetzt doch eine
rampe und der schlitten offiziere
das ist mal wieder alle haben es
geschafft
auch silvia japan-krise grau aber es ist
wirklich guter letzt hat und sie sowieso
ganz gut läuft ganz gut
[Musik]
nobitz leben trotz müdigkeit packen sie
nun alle an und unterstützen sich
gegenseitig keine spur von chaos
denn unser tode wenn sap zu tode
die wirtschaft nach einem krupp und das
warum ich so schnell bin ich weiß also
wenn ich meine da und da mal nicht in
crysis 2 3 liter am tag
und ich glaube die thermosflasche mehrin
hält man kann man sich bei wolff und
sich nützlich wo man sollte man sagen
ein bisschen aber immer halt nie gegen
die zeit und man muss sehr schnell
feststellen wir selber ist es auch so
entstanden und ich muss sagen ist erhöht
worden um abgaben 788 wie schlägt man
sie sind unbedingt wirklich an robert
gibbs meinte liga jetzt hat china
es ist der dritte tag und mit nur wenig
ratschläge funktionieren sie jetzt gut
als team kein grund zur sorge mehr
sie haben die hunde richtig festgemacht
graben gleicher für die hunde helfen
sich gegenseitig jetzt warten wir nur
noch bis das essen fertig ist
lasst sie schlafen rennen wenn es nötig
ist schlafen wenn sie können das macht
einen erfahrenen schlitten und aus noch
können sich die teilnehmerinnen nicht
ausruhen
silvia hat nach diesem harten tag
schmerzen im knie und ist sich nicht
sicher ob es etwas ernstes ist
michelle die physiotherapeutin kümmert
sich um sie dass er auch nur eine erste
entwarnung michelle vermutet eine
muskuläre überlastung verursacht durch
die ungewohnten bewegungen auf dem
schlitten silvia hofft auch morgen mit
dabei zu sein
auch für die alte hundedame jazz gibt es
heute eine willkommene überraschung
statt in der kälte bei minus 20 grad
darf sie mit im zelt übernachten
[Musik]
sie helfen
morgen geht es weiter mit der längsten
etappe auf der husky tour des lebens
[Musik]
geplant präsentiert vorkommt die kreise
spezialist für den norden
konkret punkt ch